je sortirai quand j'aurai envie sortir
parce que j'aurais été cités qui s'en
est sorti et quand les suicides
je voudrais sortir nous enverra trois
oui mais là c'est le sens de ta gueule
gibrat vite que ce que j'avais sur mon
passage et jamie bell
on voudrait bien vous ouvrir la barrière
je vois bien que vous êtes honnête non
[Musique]
julyvonne c'est papa viennent baho
fonctionnent en binôme pour montech
enterprise
quel est le motif de votre visite
monsieur j'ai pas envie de montrer le
dernier qui décline
ça ne m'intéresse pas open bar open bar
amusez-vous janvier qui a testé à
orvault il voudrait il reprendre de
l'école peut présenter je suis je
déteste l'autorité narcissisme la bêtise
qu'on sait qu'on votait un bon père qui
est là quand il a besoin de toi
[Musique]
voyons à trouver une femme n'en avons le
gamin je suis beaucoup plus intellectuel
que toi j'ai un chien côté raffiné un ga
testicules coincé
szajner où je suis pas loser salon tu
voudrais sentirait quoi et où tout peut
pas il allait partir +4 office on veut
pas choses fonctionnent en binôme va
monter une lenteur price quand tu
commences secouriste du monde quand tu
commences à fumer ça fait mal
j'apprenais en fumée c'est un projet que
nous enlève un projet comment j c'est un
peu bizarre
[Musique]
ils ont toujours foncé qu'est-ce qui
vous ont renforcé d'accord cas là on
devient eux
audrina dû être fiers nous on paie là
c'est pas le truc c'est jeu tant qu'on
est pas qu il a failli devenir taxi la
fin des visites m'ont découragé je sais
pas ce que vous avez comme grains dans
la tête vous êtes débile
tu vos mains c'est bien de ma mère
c'est vrai c'est un peu bizarre c'est un
peu bizarre
[Musique]